[Music]
what
Hello friends what a blessing and a
privilege for us is to share this
special program with you this is I'd
like to know the program that most of
you enjoy the most as is the program
that allows us to answer your questions
the inquiries that you sent us and we
want to invite you to continue to send
them you can send them to TV Sam tv.org
and let us know where are you from we
love to know the location the country or
the city in which you live that way we
can actually know how far and wide the
message and our programs are reached are
are sent around the world so thank you
for allowing us to get to know you
better and we thank you for again making
this program one of the favorites for
you and as well as for us as we can
study we can prepare ourselves to answer
the questions according to the word of
God I have the privilege today to be
with Pastor Steven bour what a blessing
to have you Pastor welcome to this
program it's always a wonderful
privilege to uh participate in this
program especially with Youk you it is
always an honor and so we are really
delighted that we can uh together answer
some of these questions that people are
sending us that are asking and those
questions some of them are really
interesting really uh unusual sometimes
I actually find myself seen through
questions that are have never thought of
so it's a blessing to really study the
word of God together so Pastor why don't
we start this program with the word of
prayer if you don't mind guiding us in
to prayer as we open God's word all
right let's
pray our father and our God what a
privilege it is to open your
word and discover what your will is for
our life amen we have so many different
questions many of them we will not be
able to answer this side of
Eternity but if we can find the answer
we ask that through your Holy Spirit you
will Enlighten us so that we might be
able to share an answer that would be
satisfactory and a blessing to those who
have sent them to us amen we ask that
you will bless this program that your
holy spirit will be present to instruct
us and to empower us Amen to live by
every word that proceeds out of your
mouth amen we pray this in the precious
name of Jesus amen amen amen all right
pastor we have this interesting question
from someone um named G and he's asking
uh a question in regards to a struggle
he's having in his life let me share
with you the this let me read the
question it says I'm an Adventist
concerning the Sabbath in the book of
Nehemiah when he closed the gates for
the Sabbath to avoid trade on God's holy
day Nehemiah placed men in front of the
gates to act as security guards to stop
trade I'm in a similar position I'm a
presidential guard in my country and I
have to perform duties on the Sabbath to
protect the president uh similar to the
Secret Service in the United States so
please assist me as I am confused some
say it's essential Services as doctors
and nurses to serve the public and
highest office my question is why did
nemiah Place guards to avoid trade on
the Sabbath isn't the same as breaking
the Sabbath as guards to perform duties
on the Sabbath I try not I try and not
claim money on the Sabbath for my duties
please assist me I'm Del deeply confused
and troubled I need and I try to and I I
need and I try to feed my family uh and
has no other source of income I don't
want to find it a pleasure to do my own
will or call the sabath of delight I
just want to provide for my family an
extended family please assist thank you
for your ministry so the question is he
has a situation where his a guard has to
protect the president and including
Sabbath Duty and he's wondering did
nemiah did wrong or right in having
guards was it necessary for that and can
he apply that to his own expressional uh
personal experience what can we say to
this pastor this is a very interesting
question well there are several issues
that he brings up here that we need to
discuss uh first of all he says that he
needs to provide for his
family um but sometimes we have to
choose between being faithful to God and
having faith in God and provid providing
for the family mhm providing for the
family would be secondary to uh being
faithful to the word of godh that's the
first thing uh you know I've heard many
individuals tell me when I preach about
the Sabbath in evangelism they say well
how am I going to feed my family you
know I have to work on Sabbath right and
if I don't work on Sabbath my family is
going to suffer need well it's a lack of
faith because God is able to allow you
to find a job where you can actually
keep the Sabbath so we need to obey God
first and leave the other in the hands
of God uh the second point is can
somebody else do the job on Sabbath or
do we have to do it you know he says
that he has to protect the president on
Sabbath however uh that's a job that
others could do as well so that's the
second Point uh the third point is that
the cases of uh the Secret Service and
his job are not parallel MH because his
job is a secular job protecting the
president whereas the guards in
nehemiah's day they were protecting the
the gates because they were protecting
God's Sabbath furthermore there's no
evidence that the guards that Nehemiah
put there were paid for their services
right to guard the gates uh so uh you
know all of these factors need to be
taken into account the bottom line is
that once you start down the slippery
slope of saying well you know um
operating a pharmacy on Sabbath is
necessary people have to get medicines
and uh you know um an individual uh
needs to transport people to church on
Sabbath so you have to drive your taxi
so once you start down that slippery
slope then the Sabbath the sacredness of
the Sabbath loses its uh its sanctity
absolutely and so uh you know doctors
and nurses that's understandable and the
spiritual prophecy makes it clear that
the money that is made on Sabbath uh
needs to be returned to for charitable
purposes because many Adventists you
know they use that uh Escape Clause yes
to be to work on Sabbath and make money
on Sabbath in that case you're working
for for remuneration for gain and so for
for financial gain and that is breaking
the Sabbath absolutely so once we take
all of those uh factors into account I'm
not sure that uh his scenario of being a
guard to the president fits the same as
those guards who were protecting the
Sabbath from being desecrated by all
these Merchants that were coming to the
gates to sell their Wares absolutely it
was a way that like you mentioned Pastor
the you know Naya saw the only way to
prevent these foreigners to come and
some locals to were conducting
transactions in Sabbath and he said
let's close these and he called for a
for a reform in the city of Jerusalem to
sanctify the Sabbath they were
profounding the Sabbath you know they
were taken for granted uh and so this is
why he made that element and he actually
set my he put his own servants he put
his own people that I guess trusted or
he trusted to to control that with a
purpose to honor God Sabbath um now
another point that you brought and then
he probably also has a confusion and you
mentioned that is about nurses and
doctors one thing is to have to do a a
sabath duty um because no one else can
you know and you and in that situation
when you're taking care of patients is
necessary absolutely but uh if you are a
doctor or a nurse and you say well you
know I'm going to work on Sabbath
because it's it's allowed for me and I
will stop you know uh but I will take
Sunday off so I can actually go spend
time with my family and have fun with my
family but I'll work on the the Sabbath
that is also a thing that has to be
analyzed by the person you know some
people don't realize that the Sabbath
should be if it's in you within your
power you within your your you know your
situation your position to avoid working
you should work avoid working at all
cost um if you are you know if you have
somebody to cover you that day it's
better to have somebody else to cover
but not to choose and say you know oh
because I am is allowed for me I'm going
to just work on Sabbath and I schedule
myself on Sabbath so I can have
Christmas off or New Year off you see
what I'm saying some people some people
use that excuse exactly you know I had a
police officer in a church that I
pastored in uh Illinois uh towards the
beginning of my Ministry and um so he
says to me uh you know people need to be
protected on Sabbath I'm a police
officer yeah and so once again I told
him once you start down this slippery
slope yeah you're going to justify many
things that are not proper to do on
Sabbath and um you know he still
continued working as a police officer um
you know he he would come to church when
he could when he had a Sabbath off but
God wants us to be in church on Sabbath
he doesn't want us to be guarding the
president on Sabbath he wants us to be
in church worshiping corporately
absolutely hearing the message singing
praises to the Lord uh and rendering the
honor that he uh that he deserves
absolutely putting your mind in harmony
with God delighting yourself in the
Sabbath and the environment which in
which he could be in or anyone that
chooses to work in instead of honoring
God when they're able to you know it's
really probably not going to be
conducive to to worship God you know
you're going to have to listen to you
know talk conversations things that are
nothing to do with the Lord and so it's
important for him to First seek God and
put him first and uh you know just
follow your conscience listen to The
Voice pray about it listen to the voice
of your conscience and then step out in
faith and do it amen you know kind of
like Israel they had to get their feet
wet when they put were going to cross
the Jordan absolutely and they did and
then the Lord did what they couldn't do
amen amen thank you this is very good I
hope that brother G can find uh the
right decision in his life let's
continue the next question Pastor comes
from Theodore and he is uh riding us
from Philadelphia Pennsylvania and his
question is this how did Nebuchadnezzar
Nebuchadnezzar know what the Son of God
looked like when he looked into the
furnace thank you God bless well Ellen
White has the answer to that and the
Bible as well right um in Daniel chapter
3 uh Nebuchadnezzar has already had
contact with uh with the Hebrew young
man with Daniel before because in
chapter one he was very impressed that
they looked better they were healthier
uh after the test and in Chapter 2
Daniel had already uh you know
interpreted his dream uh and told him
what the dream was so they they were
acquainted and there's no doubt that
Daniel and his three friends spoke about
God absolutely and uh what God what God
actually looked like because we're
talking about Christ here not talking
about God the father right Ellen White
makes this clear in the book Christ
triumphant page one 78 she wrote the
Hebrew captives had told Nebuchadnezzar
of Christ the Redeemer that was to come
and from the description thus given the
king recognized the form of the forth in
the fiery furnace as the Son of God so
they had already talked to him about
Christ the Redeemer that was going to
come and they had actually described to
him what he looked like and uh it's
interesting in to notice uh going to
Daniel chapter 3 um there's a very
interesting uh parallel that we find
there and um I'll look up Daniel chapter
3 and uh by the way Nebuchadnezzar knew
that the Son of God was Michael the
Archangel uh how do we know that well
Daniel
3:25 when Daniel sees the fourth person
in the furnace yes he says look look I
see four men loose walking in the midst
of the fire and they are not hurt and
the fourth the form of the fourth is
like the son of godh so he says the
fourth looks like the Son of God but who
was that person notice verse 28 verse
Nebuchadnezzar spoken saying saying
blessed be the god of Shadrach mesach
and Abednego who sent his Angel and
delivered his servants M interesting and
the word angel in the new King James
version is capitalized the first letter
is capitalized which means that this is
not a common Angel right this is Michael
the Archangel who is mentioned then in
chapter 12 uh so so the answer to the
question is that the the Hebrews had
spoken to Nebuchadnezzar and described
to him what Michael the Archangel looked
like and therefore he says he's like the
Son of God but he knew that the Son of
God was Michael amen amen that is very
very clear like you mention P Pastor the
spirit prophecy does make that clear
that it was through the teachings the
examples the testimony of those you know
Hebrew boys that Nebuchadnezzar
understood or knew about who God who
Jesus was to them you know and then
obviously as you mentioned here he
recognized the Son of God and then he
recognized that was Michael the
Archangel prise the Lord it can't be you
know the interesting thing is it says
the Son of God mhm which there's two
persons there would be the father and
the son yes even in the Old Testament
exactly he and and of course the the
Jews they have struggles explaining how
uh there's an individual who's the son
of God maybe this is the reason why uh
the religious leaders didn't like Jesus
when he said that he was God's son
because they knew that he was talking
about that person in Daniel that
delivered Daniel from the Lion's then
and also the three young men from the
furnace and and and that's another thing
Jews don't really like the Book of
Daniel because it really points out so
many things about Jesus and his role in
as in Prophecy as well but but yes uh so
I we want to invite Theodore to read
also uh prophets and Kings page 509
paragraph two it's also um another place
where the spirit prophecy basically
reaffirms what you just mentioned that
it was because he knew who Jesus was
through the example for the testimony of
the young Hebrew boys all right let's
continue with this with thir question we
have today and we
um this is the question uh I have a
question Ivan sends us a question that
says I have a question concerning
attending weddings on Sabbath is it okay
for as SDA person to go to a wedding
party dinner where waitresses and other
paid workers will be laboring to serve
the guest on Sabbath hours I'm asking
because I have heard arguments that
Jesus attend those kind of Ceremonies
and that it is not breaking the fourth
Commandment if an Adventist person goes
to a wedding on Sabbath I would like to
know what is your opinion thanks Ivan
this is an interesting question pastor
and um before I get you to answer you
know let me share that I was uh invited
by um at one point by somebody to do a
to a wedding on a
Sabbath and Sabbath afternoon it was and
because I was a little surprised
actually almost shocked to be honest
Pastor that uh the person that requested
the you know who invited us uh was an
Adventist was an Adventist and it was
gonna be taking place the ceremony the
wedding ceremony an Adventist Church on
Saturday afternoon was not after Sunset
Was Before Sunset and I was really
surprised I said this is interesting how
is it possible that um an Adventist
wedding on the Sabbath you know ours now
he was marrying a non-adventist
and uh which is a red flag in itself
exactly and then she was a Catholic
anyway just to make this story even
weirder you know it was somebody that
was kind of family to so uh I you know I
decid okay well is a ceremony the the
the celebration the things is later you
know it is maybe it's going to be done
in a way that I haven't seen before so I
decided to go this is a few years ago
was you were you officiated no no no no
no no I was just invited to attend you
know no I would have I know what I would
have said but I was you know early on in
Ministry you're a little confused things
like this are come to your way and
you're not sure you know so I said okay
maybe six I I wanted to find out you
know I said okay maybe the ceremony
aspect can be on this Sabbath you know
in a special way I guess I was kind
ofing this and so as I go you know I
attend the
ceremony it really shocked me because um
who was performing the ceremony in an
Adventist Church was not a pastor as the
pastor but a Catholic priest in the
adven church in the church it was
performing this wedding so I I was very
disappointed obviously you know and the
ceremony I wouldn't say was necessarily
um you know uh uh SAC relgious something
like that it was very very very solemn
in some ways but I I really got confused
and I felt this is not how we were
supposed to do this is this is contrary
to God's word this is again my
impression of that time so uh you know I
feel that we are to be very careful to
you know not perform things that can be
done in another day on the Sabbath day
we I think we have seen this and sort of
mentioned this before you know things
can be avoided on the Sabbath we should
definitely do them another day and and
in this case I was I was just surprised
that a church would allow that to happen
that they allowed this you know marriage
to happen in in in the Sabbath hours I
really was very surprised and very
disappointed with that
experience God married Adam and Eve on a
Friday yeah so there's really no
biblical example of a wedding that took
place on the Sabbath now there are
several things that we need to take a
look at to make a decision yeah um I
don't think that a marriage ceremony on
the Sabbath in an Adventist Church
between two Adventists where there is no
reception it's a simple ceremony yeah
declaring the man and wife I don't
necessarily see that that is a bad thing
right or problematic the big problem
with weddings is the preparation yes you
know the the dressing and the hair and
the you know preparing employing lots of
individuals to do the catering and the
cameras and the pictures and then when
the people get together in the reception
they're talking about secular things
because they're not going to talk about
Bible things in a reception yeah and so
it's everything that goes in with the
preparation of the wedding that's the
problem yeah uh but a simple wedding
where the cou stand in front of the
pastor the pastor they do the vows and
he pronounces them man and wife and
that's it that's the ceremony yeah you
know it's kind of like a baptismal
ceremony it's kind of like
a renew of vows as well yeah or vow
renewal the problem is with all of the
trimmings right that go along with the
wedding yes and you know the Bible the
Bible doesn't say one way or the other
but the Bible speaks in principles yes
and uh in Isa Isaiah Chapter 58 we have
the principle mhm Isaiah 58 and verse 13
if you turn away your foot from the
Sabbath from doing your pleasure on my
holy day God says and call the Sabbath a
delight the holy day of the Lord
honorable and shall honor him not doing
your own ways nor finding your own
pleasure nor speaking your own words
then you should delight yourself in the
Lord and and so on so the Bible gives us
the principles and people need to listen
to their conscience they need to be
sincere and say is this wedding ceremony
and everything that goes along with it
is it in harmony with God's will does it
Focus me on God does it does it uh help
me reverence the hours of the Sabbath
and if your answer is no then plan your
wedding some other day it's better to
have the wedding some other day because
that way you can have your reception you
know people the ladies can do their hair
and they can do their dressing and you
know the catering can come and you can
pay the Caterers and everything it's
better to do it on another day I don't
know why uh people would want to have uh
you know Adventist would want to have a
wedding on the Sabbath and also as you
mentioned you know there you have people
that you have to pay Caterers picture
you know video photographers all those
people that are not you know they're
there to do perform a job so why would
you violate the saath and I think that
connecting to the story or the question
we had at the beginning you know from
Nehemiah Nehemiah put those guards to
guard the people from you know breaking
the Sabbath to uh you know dishonor the
Sabbath by selling by buying by doing
trade so therefore if we are to be
examples today to the world that we
honor God and we keep the Sabbath holy
we are to let the Sabbath be the day of
the Lord and be only for Holy purposes
you know for things that will uplift us
to the Lord and and yeah like you
mentioned like I said you know maybe
that my idea was okay it's a small
ceremony but it was not like that so it
really was a shock and um now the
question I think I have maybe Ivan also
has this question what about if you are
invited to a wedding by a non-believer
non-adventist would that be okay to do
it on Saturday hours there's plenty of
weddings that are going on Saturday you
know by by people you know secular
people should we participate of them if
they expect us to be because we're
family members for example yeah you know
I I would not you know some people do
this to please the family yeah the
question is what's most important
pleasing God or pleasing the family yeah
you know if you take a stand you say and
you explain nicely you know the Sabbath
is the day that we're supposed to focus
on spiritual things on the Lord and I
feel like if I come to the wedding with
the reception and everything it's going
to distract from the Central purpose of
the Sabbath and explain it at least if
if you're really nice in the way that
you explain it yeah uh if they don't
understand they'll be less angry with
you I think uh but they don't understand
that it's not family that comes first
what they don't understand is that God
comes first and your example will be a
good witness to them absolutely uh
whereas if you go go to the wedding and
the Temptation is always to talk about
secular things you know worldly things
and uh you know many times the food is
not the kind of food that you would
regularly eat so there's all kinds of
issues when you come to that now uh I
noticed here uh in this question
something very interesting the argument
that is used is that
Jesus uh attended a wedding on the on
the Sabbath well the fact is there's no
reference to the wedding in Kaa taking
place on the Sabbath you can't use uh if
Jesus married Adam and Eve on
Friday there's no evidence that uh
really Jesus attended a wedding ceremony
on the Sabbath in Canaan there's no
evidence of that some people have argue
I've heard this argument because
weddings could take seven days sometimes
in the old days that it was you know he
was celebrating 7even days you know but
but when did the seven days begin
exactly and and you know I believe that
is a different we have not really
understood perhaps the type of culture
and how it was I'm sure that Christ did
not Prof you know profane the Sabbath by
by doing his own will or or or en
joining in conversations that were not
cond to the to the the will of God uh if
they were several days those weddings
did take place and they pass to the
Sabbath I do believe that it was a uh
you know they will actually honor God
correctly and keep himself holy so um
yeah yeah so you know whatever we do on
the
Sabbath has to keep our focus on the
sanctity of the Sabbath yeah that's the
that's the principle you know does what
we do on a certain on a certain Sabbath
detract us from what the Sabbath is all
about which is to focus on our creator
how wonderful he is yeah and not
distract us uh to human uh everyday
Affairs absolutely and and you know not
AUM either because again there's no
evidence biblically that Jesus spent
more than you know than a day on a feast
uh even though like I said some people
have said that they to take forever or
take seven days that's assumptions
there's Bible that never say anywhere
where Christ was on a feast on or or a
or a marriage on the Sabbath day yeah
you know sometimes there's these
Traditions that enter the Adventist
Church like for example ell white said
that uh the trip to Heaven is going to
take seven days because everybody has to
keep one Sabbath before they enter the
kingdom yeah well you know that's just a
conjecture uh there's no first of all
Ellen White doesn't say that they have
to keep a Sabbath before they get there
she does say that the trip to Heaven is
going to take seven days it would be an
assumption yeah that we're going to
arrive there on a Sabbath yes so we need
to be careful about assumptions amen
well we look forward to the next time we
can meet with you thank you for your
partic anticipation send us your
questions let us know uh how we can God
willing answer the questions correctly
by the grace of God may God bless you
see you next
[Music]
time